so three years ago as BLM riers torched
businesses throughout her State little
known uh a little known woman by the
name of Fanny Willis was campaigning to
become the district attorney in Fulton
County Georgia now she was running
against the incumbent da Paul Howard who
hadn't faced a serious Challenger in
more than two decades now in normal
times this would have been a Longshot
campaign but Willis knew that the moral
Panic after George Floyd's overdose
death made District Attorneys unpopular
all over the country she was uh facing a
once in a-lifetime opportunity to take
out Howard so she went for it Willis's
campaign strategy was pretty simple she
accused Paul Howard of corruption and
painted herself as an alternative watch
fonny Willis SP 17 years employed as a
prosecutor by Fulton County district
attorney Paul Howard now she faces
Howard in Tuesday's runoff and she's not
at all shy about clobbering her former
boss when asked about the contest think
it's a choice actually between um
integrity and Corruption good and bad I
think it's a a classic fight um and I
think that citizens will have to make a
choice we have a district attorney now
that works for his own self-interest uh
seems to care about the things that
benefit him and not the community I
think it's a choice actually between
integrity and Corruption good and bad
says Fanny Willis that's an argument
that resonated in Falon County probably
because Paul Howard was indeed corrupt
so later that year Willis overwhelmingly
defeated Howard and became Fon County's
district attorney the problem for
residents of Fallon County Georgia is
that Willis's entire campaign turned out
to be as is so often the case in
political campaigns a textbook example
of the uh psychological phenomenon known
as projection Fanny Willis we're now
learning is in fact an order of
magnitude more corrupt than Paul Howard
she's not simply accused of skimming a
small amount of money from taxpayers or
failing to disclose some conflicts of
interest to be clear Fanny Willis is
accused of both of those things as I'll
explain in a moment but unlike Paul
Howard fan Wills is also now accused of
something far more serious She's accused
of using taxpayer money to hire her
lover who's a Suburban lawyer with zero
experience Prosecuting Rico cases to
prosecute the former president of United
States on the single most untested
strained application of RICO law that's
ever been conceived in other words Fanny
Willis is so interested in this guy that
she's willing to engage in a little
election interference for him allegedly
and she's charging her constituents to
do it these accusations against Wills
came in a court filing from Mike Roman
one of uh the Trump staffers who made
the mistake of trying to seat an
alternate slate of electors back in 2020
not that you know the law and history
matter anymore but it is worth pointing
out that attempting to seat an alternate
slate of ele electors is something
that's always been legal in this country
it was legal back in 1960 when John F
Kennedy's campaign did it for good
reason creating an alternate slate of
electors makes sense when uh a campaign
suspects election fraud because they
want to give Congress the opportunity to
use their electors if the fraud is
ultimately discovered nothing about the
process is scandalous nothing about it
is new and it's all completely logical
but the idea of alternate electors is
apparently illegal now because the
orange man is bad and so forth so Fon
county is Prosecuting Roman and in
response Roman proceeded to uh blow
Fanny Willis's love affair wide open
Watch explosive allegations Tonight from
One of former president Donald Trump's
co-defendants right here in Georgia he
has some pretty bold claims about fton
County district attorney fonnie Willis
Atlanta news first anchor Tory Cooper
has been digging through that Court
filing so Tori what are they actually
claiming here well tonight former Trump
campaign staffer Michael Roman and his
attorney Ashley Merchant are claiming
district attorney fonnie Willis had an
inappropriate and romantic relationship
with the top prosecutor in the case
Nathan Wade in this new court filing
obtained by Atlanta news first Michael
Roman and his attorneys are accusing the
fand County DA fonnie Willis and special
prosecutor Nathan Wade of having an
inappropriate and romantic relationship
and that the two benefited from it the
suit claims Willis and Wade took lavish
vacations together and that he used part
of his salary from the DA's office to
travel with Willis Roman's attorney
claims they discovered that the two win
on trips together quote outside of court
filings the suit goes on to claim the
relationship began before Wade was
appointed to the case they claim Willis
also failed to get County approval to
appoint Wade as special prosecutor in
the case Roman's attorneys are now
asking the court to disqualify both of
them from Prosecuting the RICO case and
to drop all of Roman's charges Roman's
attorneys wouldn't comment any further
tonight and fonny Willis's office told
us they will be responding to Roman suit
through proper court
filings now the uh the news people seem
kind of surprised by this accusation but
but they really shouldn't be if they
were keeping track they'd remember that
this is not the first time that Fanny
Willis has gotten into trouble over a
serious conflict of interest a year ago
a judge in in Georgia barred Willis from
investigating one of Trump's alleged
fraudulent electors a state senator
named Berke Jones why did she get barred
from uh from that well because Fanny
Willis hosted a fundraiser for a
Democrat running against Jones for his
seat this is something that no serious
prosecutor or anybody with an IQ above
room temperature would have ever done to
reiterate Fanny Willis literally raised
money for someone who was running
against the defendant she was trying to
throw in prison now I played this clip
last year but it's worth revisiting
because of how remarkable it is here's
the judge who by the way judge is not
exactly the picture of masculinity but
he's doing his best to dress down Fanny
Willis in the most deferential way
possible but even this judge who's
clearly on her side and doesn't want to
have to deal with this even he still has
something to say about how egregious
this is
watch um using the title of your office
and having on social media that you as
this political office holder are holding
a fundraiser for the opponent of someone
that this political office is
investigating um I don't know that it's
an actual conflict but um I use that
phrase what were you thinking where the
prosecutor thought I could prosecute the
codefendant of someone I
defended it's a what are you thinking
moment um the
Optics are horrific if you are trying to
have the public believe that this is a
nonpartisan driven by the
facts I'm not here to critique decisions
the decision was made but if we are
trying to maintain confidence that this
investigation is pursuing facts in a
nonpartisan sense noes matter who the
district attorney is we follow the
evidence where it goes and ignore the
fact that I hosted a fundraiser for the
political opponent of someone I've just
named a
Target that that strikes me as
problematic so like I said the judge
doesn't exactly lay the hammer down he
could have been uh a lot more forthright
shall we say but in his own wishy-washy
way even he is shocked by her behavior
and this is the moment that Willis
should have been disqualified from
Prosecuting any of these Trump criminal
cases frankly she should have been
investigated by the State Bar and maybe
suspended from practicing law it was
that bad but she wasn't she got this
milk toast effeminate scolding and she
was allowed to continue making a
complete mockery of the judicial system
and that's exactly what she's
done to be clear yes Mike Roman's
accusations against Fanny Willis are
unproven as of now but they were made
public last week and Willis remained
silent at the time this is the kind of
thing that you'd think a prosecutor
would immediately deny I mean if if it's
not
true then there's no reason to not come
out and say that's not true that's
totally made up you're insane but she
didn't say that instead Willis waited
until Sunday to address Roman's
accusations and she chose to deliver her
remarks addressing this this claim of a
of a of a major Scandal she chose to
address it not in front of the press who
could have asked her some follow-up
questions not that the Press necessarily
would have even done that but instead
she chose to address it in front of a
sympathetic audience at a black church
in Atlanta at no point in Her speech
which lasted more than 30 minutes we'll
look at a few clips of it at no point
did Willis deny the accusations against
her which is which is you know
effectively the same as admitting that
they're true instead she launched into
maybe the single most Brazen attempt to
play the race card in the history of
this country I mean this is one of the
worst I know that's saying something
this is somehow even worse than Claudine
gay saying you're racist if you care
about plagiar
uh it's even more Preposterous than
Marian Barry the former DC mayor
implying that you hate black people if
you're upset that he's on camera buying
crack in hotel rooms uh somehow it's
even more obnoxious and egregious than
any of that just watch and Marvel at
this but dear God are you
listening why does commissioner Thorne
and so many others question my decision
in a special counsil Lord you're flawed
hard-headed and imperfect child I'm a
little
confused I appointed Three Special
counselers is my right to do paid them
all the same hourly rate they only
attack
one I hired one white woman a good
personal friend and great
lawyer a superstar I tell you I hired
one white man brilliant my friend and a
great
lawyer and I hired one black man another
Superstar a great
friend and a great lawyer oh Lord they
going to be mad when I call them out on
this
nonsense first thing they
say oh she going to play the race card
now but no God isn't it them who's
playing the race card when they only
question
one this is the kind of race card gamb B
that you very rarely see this is like
trying to shoot the moon uh here you
have the person who's playing the race
card trying to imply that you're playing
the race card by noticing that she's
playing the race card so she's playing
to mix our card game analogy she's
playing kind of the Reverse Racism UNO
card it's astonishing to watch mainly
because it makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever the sheer incoherence is uh
incredible to behold her AR arent
appears to be that she hired Three
Special prosecutors and two of them are
white and everybody's upset about the
black guy so clearly everybody's racist
but she's just not going to mention the
accusation that she's having sex with
the black guy like that's the thing that
makes the black guy notable over the
white guys she's not having sex with the
white guys she's having sex with the
black guy uh and she's the one who chose
the black guy to have sex with me if
anyone's guilty of discrimination it's
like she's the one who chose to have the
affair with that guy not the other guys
and that's the issue here but you know
all of that is completely immaterial
according to Fanny Willis she's also not
going to talk about um you know how this
job has made this special prosecutor
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
taxpayer money money that he has
reportedly used to take Fanny Willis on
vacations to the Caribbean and Napa
Valley it's hard to believe but somehow
Willis has managed to uh with this
Scandal and her response to it she's
managed to
discredit a prosecution that nobody ever
took seriously to begin with like she
she has managed to divide by zero she
has removed credibility from something
that had none to begin with I mean
nobody ever seriously believed that the
brilliant legal Scholars working in the
government in Fon County Georgia were
going to be able to prosecute a RICO
case against the presidential front
runner for the crime of challenging
election results everyone knew it would
be a disaster but even given those low
expectations Willis has managed to
impressively tank her case even
further and by the end of this uh you
know the prosecutors might be the ones
going to jail or they should
be but Willis appears to be too stupid
to realize that at least uh as of now so
she just kept on talking listen you
cannot expect black women to be perfect
and save the
world the lord is completing us we are
not perfect that's right we need your
prayers we need to be allowed to stumble
we need Grace with that kind of support
we will move mountains and do Jesus's
will stumbling all the
way now put aside the implication that
this is the that it's the will of God to
have Donald Trump arrested she says
quote you cannot expect black women to
be perfect and save the
world but of course nobody expects or is
asking for either of those
things and and what you hear here this
is one of the most bizarre fantasies on
the left which is that black women are
somehow especially
persecuted while also being especially
gifted and courageous and
heroic but the reality of course is that
black women are not persecuted at all in
fact you know they're among the least
persecuted oppressed people in the world
in the history of the world in fact
they're given preferential treatment in
virtually every aspect of American life
in the media corporate hiring College
admissions the intersectional
intersectional math uh the the victim
hierarchy Works wildly in their favor if
there's one thing that matters most to
me in this life it's those I love and
thanks to my friends at Pure Talk they
are beating today's inflation and making
it easier to connect with those
important people in your life if you're
like me there's not not a day that goes
by that I don't call or text someone I
care about um well I don't I never call
anybody ever but I do text
sometimes uh you know it'll take three
and a half weeks before I respond to it
but I do respond anyway that don't think
about me think about Pure Talk Pure Talk
gives you phenomenal coverage on
America's Most Dependable 5G Network
it's the same coverage you know and love
but for half the price of the other guys
with unlimited plans starting at just 20
bucks a month the average family saves
almost $1,000 a year as a veteran-owned
company last year alone they raised $10
million towards veterans debt what's
more pure talks customer service team is
located right here in the US and can
help you make the switch in as little as
10 minutes so I challenge you to stand
with a company that Champions your
values today just go to Pur talk.com
Walsh to make the switch and right now
my viewers will save an additional 50%
off your first month that's Pur talk.com
walshay Willis got you know a million
positive profiles in the media simply
for being a black woman who's
Prosecuting Donald Trump
and everybody knows this which is why
people like Willis constantly have to
remind us that they're victims so the
whole speech went on like this a few
minutes later after some more self-pity
Fanny Willis reiterated that God wants
her to prosecute the presidential front
runner she kind of sneaks that in uh
every now and then and then she goes
back to self-pity
listen I'm here to tell you
something and it may make some of y'all
a little
uncomfortable God's using Ordinary
People to do extraordinary
things I come real
regular in fact when I meet people
that's what they say real regular you
don't have no erors about
yourself and I say well how can I I I
come from regular
folk I ain't got no
pedigree I'm not a member of any of
those Elite organizations
and one more thing I'm as flawed as they
[Applause]
come but there is something special
about me it's my willingness to love
people I love people of every political
party different viewpoints different
races different
sexuality and one thing you will come to
learn about me is I make sure everyone
else is good sometimes I'm
not Fanny Willis is a great person says
Fanny Willis she's also really humble
and she's grounded oh and she's carrying
on God's plan to take out the political
enemies of the democratic
party any
questions well no of course there's no
question she deliberately addressed this
in a venue where there are no questions
allowed in fact she went to a venue
where people literally Shout amen that's
where she decided to go to talk about
this major Scandal now it's worth
pausing for a
moment um just to emphasize that Willis
is is not an exception on the left you
know she's not the only prominent
leftist to make a mockery of
Christianity like this remember it was
the governor of New York uh who went to
a church and told Christian worshippers
that quote God wants you to be
vaccinated and now we have Fanny Willis
telling us that God wants to incarcerate
the Je presidential front runner and the
enemies of of the faith always do this
they can't help themselves they
desperately want to use Christian
beliefs to advance their cause even as
they hate
Christians and and you know every time
it comes off it's hammy and laughable uh
and and you know uh incredibly cynical
and
transparent they think that if they
bastardize Christianity through politics
they can use the faith to control Christ
Christians Fanny Willis knows she has no
defense for what she's done but instead
of taking ownership for it which is
which is what Christians would tell you
to
do yes as Christians we believe um no
human being is perfect uh we believe in
Mercy we believe in forgiveness but we
also know that there's no forgiveness
without
repentance and we're not hearing any
repentance from her far from
it and and by the way even if we do
forgive someone as a Christian uh for
doing something say engaging in a
political Scandal even if you forgive
them which would would require
repentance which require an admission of
guilt repentance that doesn't mean that
you forget about it and then say oh yeah
they're still qualified to you know be a
DA Prosecuting a former
president of course
not so she's trying to invoke
Christianity while understanding nothing
about it I mean it's doubtful she's ever
opened a Bible in her entire life right
she doesn't know I she she she probably
couldn't like list the gospel she
probably thinks that punches pilot was
like an airline Captain okay and uh and
for what it's worth um along with trying
to invoke the Bible she also invoked
history that she doesn't understand as
well towards the end of her speech she
uh for good measure compared herself to
Martin Luther King Jr uh watch see Dr
King was an
extremely special brilliant
godly man but he was just a man yes and
his journey was full of mistakes yes
pitfalls pain and
ugliness despite all of that he overcame
those things and he changed the entire
world see I know we are at a time of
history when they want to throw away
books and not talk about history some of
y'all May have forgotten when Dr King
was alive he was attacked for his stance
on the Vietnam War some of y'all might
have forgotten that Scandal the FBI
tried to do on personal indiscretions
they some of y'all forgot that but now
that same FBI will take a day off to
celebrate Dr King cuz my lord said you
will make them your foot
schol ah yes ml K made mistakes just
like Fanny Willis of course MLK's quote
unquote mistakes included being a
communist and adulterer and allegedly
watching and laughing as a woman was
raped uh that's the mistakes that she's
referring to maybe Fanny Wills is trying
to tell us something here maybe there
are more shoes to drop I don't know
maybe the FBI is going to come after her
too somehow that seems unlikely given
that in this comparison it's Fanny
Willis doing exactly what the FBI wants
her to do
by trying to take out Donald Trump but
it's not worth thinking too deeply about
anything Fanny Willis said because
there's really no meaning in any of it
it's all just
misdirection so we're left with the
substance of the
accusations against Fanny Willis which
she effectively admitted are true in her
remarks on
Sunday you know when someone accuses you
of something and you don't deny it and
instead you say Hey Nobody's Perfect
well like that's as close you can come
to admitting it without admitting it and
what does means is that the Fulton
County prosecution of Donald Trump isn't
just politically motivated it's not just
completely meritless on the law we knew
that
already what what's new is that this
prosecution which again is the
prosecution of the leading candidate for
the president of the United States um is
also motivated by a corrupt Prosecutor's
desire to shower her boyfriend with
vacations to the Caribbean and Napa
Valley and also shower herself with
those things by extension and and that's
what these people mean when they say
that they're defending democracy this is
what they mean when they accuse you of
racism when they invoke MLK in the Bible
they don't understand or believe
anything they're
saying that's been obvious to anyone
who's been paying attention for
years and now thanks to yesterday's
performance by Fanny Willis it's
hopefully obvious to
everyone hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months fre on all
annual plans see you there